so
you're a navy pilot for 18 years yes
can you briefly tell the story of your
career as a pilot
yeah um so you know first i was i was
enlisted i was a marine
and then the marines actually sent me
recommended me to go to the naval
academy so it's always better to be
lucky than good but i got to go to the
naval academy and i
finished and i've had that dream to fly
so when i got selected
they've always dreamed of flying yeah
since
1969 when i watched neil armstrong walk
on the moon
um i was at that point i asked my mom i
remember watching it i was
i was just prior to being five and i
said
wow yeah it's so cool mom and she said
well you know they were all pilots
and uh then at that point it was like
i'm gonna be a pilot
and if you knew me growing up because i
was a little bit of a delinquent
people are just like yeah right i used
to joke i'm gonna fly i'm gonna fly jets
and i'm gonna drop bombs
then and if people that knew me when i
was a kid they would be like yeah and
they'd be like
not a chance and then when i did i
actually had a
it's a funny story and i'll get to it
i'll finish my career but
i was at my cousin's wedding and uh we
all grew up in the same neighborhood
uh we kind of they had italian side
of the family that's how we grew up so
it was my house right down the street is
my cousin chad and right around the
corner my cousin ray and my aunts and
uncles and stuff
the guy two doors down from my and i was
a paper boy in the neighborhoods they
all knew me
and uh i went to my cousin's wedding and
he and and mr race looks at me and he
says
david fravor i go mr race how you doing
you guys
you fly jets top gun and all that i go
yes sir
i guess i figured he'd be in jail by now
um
it was kind of a to me it was a little
bit of a badge of honor going on you
know i kind of overcame that but uh
what do you attribute that to so you
i've heard you before and just now i'll
say
that uh it's better be it's better to be
lucky than good and you you talk
modestly about uh
about just being lucky but
if you were to describe your trajectory
maybe in a way of advice like
retrospectively
uh how how'd you pull it off to be like
to be truly a special person the easiest
way is one
never never take no don't let anyone put
you down and say you can't do it or
those i mean i knew i knew what i was
capable of inside
you know and if i really believe if you
want something and you want to do
something then you you can
achieve it not in all cases like if i
loved basketball
and i really wanted to be in the nba
there's a realism that says
i'm five foot eight and i got like a
really short vertical leap and i'm
really not that good at basketball it's
probably not ever going to happen no
matter how hard i try and practice
it's just the way it is or for me to be
in the nfl
i'm not fast you know i'm not that big
it's just physically i'm incapable of
doing that
but there's things that don't really tie
to a true physical ability as far as
size and strength but
it's it's mental uh and i'm not saying
you have to be a genius and super smart
to be a fighter pilot matter of fact you
don't
it really comes down to the ability to
think very quickly
uh 80 solution is typically good enough
because if you overthink it you're
you're behind and then in an air-to-air
fight that's what happens people try and
overthink it
and before you know it because it's
happening so fast you don't have
you can't get to the nth degree you know
six decimal places
eighty percent solution is good enough
you've built up a really strong gut for
the eighty percent solution just yeah
i'm a big believer in eighty percent
solution i love that
if you get eighty percent you can go and
then you can always adjust
which is exactly what like if you're
fighting in bfm the 80
solution is it's like a chess game but
it's a really really fast chess game
where you go
i'm doing this and then i know that if i
do a maneuver
if he's going to counter it correctly he
should do a
if he doesn't do a he does some degree
less like b
c d and then i know how bad his his
error is
and then i capitalize so my might i
don't have to be perfect you know i have
to go i need to go to 47 degrees nose
high
if i just kind of get above 40 then i'm
good and i can watch how he reacts and
then i can adjust for that and
and you continually work that problem
and you chip away because if you start
neutral
you're just basically chipping away and
gaining advantage advantage advantage
till eventually
you know in if you're really you know
fighting you know just guns only
recorder where you got to get behind the
guy
kind of world war two dogfighting type
stuff um
then it's it's literally it's a it's a
very very fast
chess game that happens at you know 400
knots 300 knots depends
so to get to be one of the rare
individuals that uh
are able to do that he just had the
dream
and didn't take no for an answer well
you know
you know part of it is family you know
uh
my dad was uh i used to call him a fire
ready aim guy
you know he'd smack me and then ask me
what i did wrong yeah
good parenting um back then you know i
joke and
and people look because you know at
times it was kind of tough you know
because he can be pretty demanding but
on the other side
you know i probably needed to be reined
in a little bit at times
uh but then everyone else my family you
know my mom was really awesome when i
was a kid
my my grandfather who is a big big part
of it my mom's
dad uh who he taught me a lot and
we you have a question there that we'll
talk about about him but a
huge huge influence very very positive
and a lot of the stuff that i do today
and decisions are based on things that
he taught me um
and uh you know i figured you know it
was the first funeral i ever went to
and it was uh it was about three miles
long and church was overfilling and
people were out he was a beer delivery
guy
dead serious and you go there someone
asked who died the pope
um so so a lot of people love them so
back to
back to my career yeah first question
because i'm getting down on rabbit hole
uh
no i when i was at the i was gonna i was
gonna stay in the marines i really
wanted to go
man i love the core i think it's uh
of all services it's that one everything
is inable and they're very very
professional and it was a great
great organization to join uh
but i went out to the nimitz on my uh
freshman cruise after your freshman year
at the naval academy you go out on a
ship and you
you're an enlisted person you get to
experience that half when i already was
enlisted so it's fine with me
because it comes up a lot would you mind
saying what the nimitz is what a ship is
like yeah so nimitz is uh an aircraft
carrier so it's
uh four and a half acres of sovereign
u.s territory that floats around the us
oceans
does it have weapons on it uh the air
wing is really the weapons it does have
defensive weapons but for the most part
it's a giant
moving airport is what it is so i was
out there watching the airplanes land
and take off
and i'm like oh and the squadrons that
were out there one of the squadrons was
a vf41 and a 14 squadron
vf-84 uh an f-14 squadron and then a
couple of a6 squadrons
and we actually ended up part pairing up
and hanging out with some of the a6
pilots and bns so it was really a neat
experience and i said
i want to do that and the way to do it
was to not to to go in the navy because
there are marine squadrons that go out
to the aircraft carriers but most of
them are land-based
you know to support the marines because
they're that that
unit that whole unit you know the marine
corps is that one surface has it all
and uh so when i graduated and i got to
uh you know i worked hard through
primary and that's where
you know i knew missy uh we were in
actually went through together missy
cummings
uh we went through primary together and
then uh i went to kings
we all selected the same time i went to
kingsville there was another guy scott
wiedemeyer uh
the three of us so i went to kingsville
scott went to beville
and missy went to meridian so the three
of us that we
had all went through we got we selected
out of primary together we all ended up
going jets
and that's that's how besides from
school i knew her at school too
the long story i got done uh got winged
it took me two years to the day from the
time i graduated the naval academy until
i got my wings and uh
through some luck i ended up getting
asics's
on the west coast which is a
side-by-side uh bomber so it's a pilot
on the left seat and the bombardier
navigator is on the right seat it was
built in the 60s
it is all weather uh and it flies low at
night and it's got a terrain mapping
radar
how many i guess is is that a good term
to use fighter jets
as a broad category for for the public
yeah that's probably
how many fighter jets are side by side
like that that was the
in the navy that was the only one the
air force the f-111 was a side by side
but the navy it was the a6 and then
there's the ea6 b which is a derivative
of
that and now that those are all gone the
a6b just went away a few years ago and
now the
e18 g growler is the replacement for the
a6b there was never a replacement for
the a6
that i flew it really became the f-18
which
the a6 could go quite a bit further
distance-wise by fuel then the hornet
and uh the horn is the f-18 yeah
is there usually two people in the plane
but they're usually like
in front and behind in uh the modern
two-seaters yes
uh but most of the tactical airplanes in
the world today are single seat
so you can see just one person one
person with the exception of
i'll probably someone will yell at me
but really with the exception of the
f-15e strike eagle and the f-18f
super hornet which is the f is a
two-seater and the g is also a
two-seater but it's more of an
electronic attack
by say full-up fighter bomber so
most of the time that you've flown in
your
like i said 18-year career is was it
two-seater
i was about half-and-half so i started
off an a6 was a two seater
then i went to single seat f-18s and i
flew those
all the way up until 2000 and
let me think 2001 to the end of 2001
and then i shifted over and started
flying the super hornets and i've flown
both of those the ease and the s but i
deployed when i had command of vfa41
i had the two c they were f squadron
you